Trascrizione: Denise RQ
Revisore: Alessandro Mannara
Buonasera.
Allora, io sono Luciano Cantini
e sono il cofondatore di Kentstrapper
che è un'azienda familiare fiorentina
che si occupa di produzione,
progettazione e vendita
di stampanti tridimensionali.
Dico familiare perché è stata fondata
nel 2011 da me, mio fratello
e da nostro padre, per poi in seguito
essere estesa anche ad altri
membri della nostra famiglia come
i miei cugini, mio zio e nostro nonno
che ci aiuta nella pulizia delle parti
plastiche che costituiscono
le stampanti stesse.
E nel corso degli anni è stata estesa
anche ad eventuali collaboratori esterni
che ci aiutano nella ricerca e nello
sviluppo.
Tornando alle stampanti tridimensionali,
esse sono macchine in grado di
riprodurre con buona precisione
un oggetto fisico, come questo che tengo
in mano, ma anche altri,
a partire da un loro modello
tridimensionale.
L'oggetto in questione viene realizzato
attraverso la sovrapposizione di
tanti strati, e a seconda della modalità
con cui vengono realizzati questi strati,
si possono avere diverse tipologie di
stampanti tridimensionali,
si possono avere stampanti che utilizzano
blocchi di resine o polimeri fotosensibili
solidificate attraverso fasci di luce
ultravioletta o puntatori laser,
si possono avere stampanti a polveri,
con cui si utilizza un letto granulare
o comunque un letto di polvere fatto
indurire o sempre con dei laser oppure
con degli inchiostri agglomeranti
particolari,
oppure si possono avere stampanti
a tecnologia FDM in cui si va
a depositare strati di materiale
termofuso.
Partendo dal nostro modello
tridimensionale infatti,
il software effettua quello che viene
definito "slicing", un affettamento del
modello, ovvero si va a suddividerlo
in tanti strati differenti,
e poi si va a ricostruirlo depositando
uno strato sopra l'altro.
Il modello da cui si parte, in particolar
modo, può essere realizzato
o da un qualsiasi software CAD
tridimensionale, quindi tramite
un vostro computer, oppure può essere
scaricato gratuitamente da Internet,
da uno dei tanti siti.
Alcuni esempi di applicazione di questa
tecnologia possono essere quello
industriale, anche in ambito meccanico
per realizzare componenti meccanici
funzionanti, oppure per realizzare anche
strumenti;
in campo archeologico, per realizzare
delle copie di reperti archeologici
come teschi e crani, o anche denti,
in quel caso di squali preistorici;
in campo artistico, per replicare ad
esempio delle copie di monumenti o
di statue;
ancora, ad esempio, possono essere
utilizzati in campo architettonico per
realizzare plastici, e nel campo
industriale per realizzare prototipi
di vasi, di calici,
di giocattoli, di statuine.
Ancora, ad esempio, in campo medico,
possono essere utilizzati per realizzare
protesi dentali, repliche di organi;
o in campo chimico, per realizzare
ad esempio, per rendere visibile quindi
a livello macroscopico, gli atomi che
costituiscono le molecole.
Quest'ultimo aspetto è molto importante
perché può essere utilizzato in campo
didattico per mostrare agli studenti
come sono fatte le molecole
e soprattutto avvicinarli appunto, in
maniera divertente, al mondo della chimica
o della medicina.
Ancora, utilizzi più particolari possono
riguardare il campo della moda
dove invece possono essere utilizzati
per realizzare vestiti o accessori
come borsette e scarpe; o ancora,
nel campo della musica per realizzare
dei prototipi di strumenti musicali.
Per concludere il campo, o meglio,
i campi della stampante tridimensionale
sono infiniti; il limite fondamentalmente
è la fantasia dell'utilizzatore,
del creativo, e possono addirittura
essere utilizzate in ambito domestico
per effettuare piccole riparazioni,
andando ad allungare il tempo di vita
di un oggetto, contribuendo quindi anche
dal punto di vista
dell'impatto ambientale,
poiché si utilizzano generalmente
materiali o riciclabili
oppure biodegradabili.
Con questo ho concluso,
grazie dell'attenzione.
(Applausi)